[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey folks here we are we might be drunk
we're doing it we're back worlds are
colliding we got a big guest
we might be tuesdays oh
we might be gay we there might be a lot
of things how are you jojo genuine
question
where are the cameras
am i on am i one here one here
one here
i notice none of them are pointing at me
oh this guy is you that's your camera
that's that's your eggs
i'm looking at you [ __ ] and i don't
see nothing oh yeah all right so do i
talk to you do i talk to the doctor
people at home talk to us hey folks
we're the hosts
yeah we're going sober today you got it
with a green tea i assume i got an
emperor's clouds mist grande just had my
chocolate chip cookie in the lobby what
what is an emperor's uh mist
don't worry about it uh no it's a green
tea it's a it's like a standard green
you want to sniff yeah you might get a
little bit of my breath on the lip there
it sounds like a good queef it's an
emperor's mist not bad right
just a typical green there's also the
jade citrus mint that's a mint
green tea and i don't care for the mint
i don't like the mint either yeah
t i associate with being sick i can't do
teeth oh interesting don't tell the
british it's like chicken noodle to me
like it's like i can't get amped up for
cause i'm like i i just my gosh i love
chicken noodles i like it too but i get
it when i'm sick i see you associate i
always think this though doesn't people
are always like if you're sick have a
little green tea but i'm like i drank
three cream teas a day right every day
and i got sick yeah so it must be how
rappers feel with scissors they're like
you need some cough medicine he's like
that's all i drink i mean i mix it with
uh hooch what scissor that's they drink
cough syrup to get [ __ ] up
i heard nikoi for the first time during
covet i'd never had it it was incredible
yeah it's great fantastic we call that a
free laps in the sobriety business is
that right yeah you take a nice night
quality whoa yeah it's pretty good
silent free laps so it is allowed well i
take the pill form i wouldn't take the
liquid because
next thing you know i'd be raping your
father on christmas eve because it does
come in a glass of shot glass exactly
yeah no don't you gotta do pill damn oh
yeah i never thought about that it
starts with mucinex pm it ends in a
[ __ ] glory hole yeah no there's
people that do that people like
alcoholic they drink hannah and
sanitizer or
whatever
damn yeah i've crushed up a towel pm and
shoved it up my ass sure snort that [ __ ]
do a line yeah that opium works too
that'll knock you right out it will
become a drill
hey
i've kicked that because it i'm immune
will you wake up it's not quality sleep
well tylenol pm and benadryl is the same
drug ah she's the same sleep drug it's
all mental what do you do do you take a
drug to sleep anything people are
starting to hate that watch by the way
really honestly that's the problem oh
damn it yeah buzzes every hour it said
uh someone wrote mark norman's watch the
guy did like three takes of it it was
one of those tweets where he deletes it
rewrites it and then writes it again uh
but he was like mark norman's watch has
interrupted more podcasts than will
smith or it didn't make sense but it
kind of made
doesn't make sense but you can see that
they don't like it yeah all right read
between the lines
[Laughter]
interrupted more pocket more comics than
kanye huh yeah i'm trying to punch it up
did he interrupt well i guess interrupt
is the wrong word
he fought with dl hewley pete davidson
and trevor noah and mike myers right is
that right oh mike myers oh yeah
he just made it weird right he just made
it weird yeah that's a different part
pete holm's buck
well d.o hewlett i didn't know he had
beef with a deal was like a former [ __ ]
i think is that right i wouldn't [ __ ]
with dl
interesting yikes it's on the deal yeah
i had no idea anymore
yeah that's uh no he's like he came from
the gangs i think i mean matt maybe
fact-check that deal
i guess he does have a neck tattoo hmm
so
maybe he got something here yeah was he
a [ __ ] the blood so oh
oh that's a big [ __ ] up right that's
like the n word for that
thanks i don't think we're supposed to
be talking about that
it's on google yeah well google's not a
person with a podcast
yeah i'm not going to stab google
[Laughter]
who's google which one was that was that
bezos google yeah no this is amazon who
did google yeah who did google who
started
zuckerberg with facebook yeah and then
there's uh the other guy larry page
trump
but who's the ceo now that's not
what's his name uh apple uh jobs
wasn't it who was the guy that nate went
on his boat and he owned the soon blazer
sundar pichai no it's not soon daryl
it's my favorite green tea
i think i hiked sundar pucci in uh peru
oh yeah october 2015. i don't think he
invented it we would have heard that
name i never heard of sundar how did
google cause it yahoo was the one that
was bing remember bing chandler bing yes
hotbot hot box
hotbot was another one ask jeeves and
that was something yeah jeeves yeah that
was in the gullman joke according to
askgeez.com that didn't last i don't
think sundar invented google but bill
gates google too soon microsoft
i don't know i suck
larry page who's that
oh guy with a bad haircut
yeah that's tough it's funny how the
richest people have the worst [ __ ]
haircuts yeah zuckerberg that's true
super cuts
yeah he's got the bangs he does it's
weird who else looking great who else
it's a long list who's that guy in
zuckerberg basically yeah
it was it was an unearned premise
doesn't have great hair no
so maybe you got something here yeah
this is three
okay everyone knows this guy you'd have
to have to bring a picture of him on
stage yeah
oh yeah well he cleaned it up i guess
yeah he's like the robbie uh uh what was
that guy's name [ __ ] uh i forgot his
name uh robbie pro
no
robbie you know robbie the golf
instructor he got the haircut he called
an instructor he's a comedian
oh rob bernstein no that's a different
guy a comedian he teaches golf robbie
collier oh collier i don't know he's a
golf team i forgot about him yeah robbie
collier he looked like that and then he
got his hair off fixed up he looks great
really i thought he looked okay before
frankly wow yeah well some women will
tell you if you're going bald just own
it baby yeah that's what's hot in a man
owning yeah well bruce willis made it
kind of cool yeah he looked good bald
yeah bruce willis george picard
john luke john luke picard yeah who's
george picard george picard is another
actor from uh that's george popard
pipard yes he's in uh my breakfast
statham
statham's hunk
yeah sexy beast sexy beast is solid look
at all these guys black guys banner
different though jason cannon
there you go trouble
alan lefkowitz
the women are attracted to him sarah
talks about how they're attracted
because he's really listening he's
thoughtful and he's listening he [ __ ]
my ex-girlfriend it was [ __ ] up man
what no alan [ __ ] my ex whoa he [ __ ]
judy gold
and my mom dude i want to [ __ ] my mom
well no better guy to talk about it with
who else who gives me some other ball
dudes bald and hot i mean william
yeah stanley tucci is kind of cute
ed harris is hot paris has got something
women like stanley tucci oh yeah
i like him
would you
yeah
i don't like how he tried to become
bourdain though that kind of buggy yeah
a lot of guys tried i wish he'd kill
himself
uh what's his face uh he's a cute guy
phillip uh rosenthal phil rosenthal try
to bourdain thing the manatee
vader loves that show really yeah he's
everybody loves raymond yeah that guy
yeah people love that show he has his
own show yeah he's got a a food show
disney ray romano's manager no no he was
he was the co-creator co-creator
ray romano i'll say is the nicest dude
the nicest comic he's the only famous
dude that pops into the cellar and is
like oh i don't want to bump you you
know yeah yeah everyone every other
famous person's like i'm gonna do an
hour and a half you're gonna [ __ ]
wait at the table you're not gonna see
your family for a while ray romano is
literally like no just you know i don't
wanna inconvenience you true great guy
and hilarious and funny yes funny comics
nice enough to do ray ellen's show
that's saying something that's nice
not aruba no okay it's not going there
no certainly not tell your aruba tony
wood story this kills me oh the time i
told it on rogan and it bombed but oh
well we're
we'll laugh
he everything goes over his uh talk
about bald hot guys oh yeah he's he's a
boldheart he's bald yeah uh tony
tony i've probably probably heard the
story a million times sorry i'm a little
horse from sporting events but tony
woods uh is in aruba and he's late for
every single show i love him and so
hilarious he's like in the eighth floor
so he's late for every single show 100
of the show is in the hotel room but
he's playing every show the ballroom so
yeah so ray ellen
in the hotel yeah ray ellen says i got
an idea i'll put him in the room across
the hall
that way he doesn't have to find his way
i can just go and get him when it's time
wow so ray ellen the first show the
second week he goes over he knocks on
the door and he says i just gave dan
adam in the light and tony woods goes
all right i'll jump in the shower
[Laughter]
he's a class it's a two-minute light
he's a classic tony woods he really is
he's always got his kavacier yeah he's
the ladies man you know i feel like i've
never connected with him because he's
more of a he's a drinky party guy and
we've never collided then i feel like if
i knew him 10 years ago we would have
gone to some titty bars and drank right
but that guy's got hours of material
he's always a funny dude yeah
classic and he does ours
you know one set but i've i love the guy
i'm a fan but i've met him 500 times and
he's like hey who are you a young
brother and i'm like yeah yeah we've met
the first 30 times he was like it's
great to meet you and i'm like it hurts
every time i know yeah every time you
say that there's a lot of guys like that
a tell was like that for a long time uh
naderman is like that for quite a while
it's these scatter brainy kind of guys
once you get in you're in but it takes a
minute is that weird that we probably do
that to people we've probably met young
comics and they're like hey nice to meet
you and they're like oh my god you're
probably right that's the therapy right
there what do you mean that you have the
awareness to just be like oh we've our
impact on young comics yeah that's you
you being in therapy yeah or it's ego
being like where are those guys now by
the way
either way
awareness that's like your
interpretation i took it as ego but yeah
really ah
and they flipped it but i think it's
also just like the idea of being like oh
this is our impact like we're talking
about these people this is what we do
well i do think that because i was
talking about this the other day i
remember being at i went to the new york
film academy as did mark back in 03 you
gotta remember walking up the village
going to the cellar and like stopping my
classmates and being like that's dan
nederman
he's like dan adams having a slice of
pizza right there you're like what i'm
like he's been on the tonight show it's
insane like literally starstruck because
i was like holy [ __ ] that's stan adamant
in the wild yeah he's been on letterman
yeah exactly we've had a couple late
nights our buddy james smith is the best
dan anderman styles oh that's a great uh
where he sees dan adams oh my god you're
dan naderman you were on letterman last
night adam just sit on the stupid goes
yeah and look at me now look where i am
now i'm on a stoop
it's great i mean he's just such a
miserable well that's how it was when
you were younger you're like oh you do
letterman you're famous the next day you
do conan you're a millionaire but you
know it's five minutes you're on with uh
snooki and uh paula deen and then you go
home yeah that's it you're doing better
than paula dean right now ah do you
remember the first uh you never admit
you gotta not admit that was the problem
with paula deen she thought she was
doing the right thing wait she's like
i've said the n word you know i'm trying
not to and then [ __ ] you piece of [ __ ]
oh interesting you should have been like
no that wasn't me i don't know what
you're talking about i feel like white
people cancel them more than black
people oh it was like i feel like yeah i
mean it was like they were like no you
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
there was a lot of memes by like the
chicken wings are good though you know
or whatever it was
they love paula dean do you remember the
first person you met who had been on tv
ooh mine was paul nardisi i remember
being at the comedy vault and he had
been on conan he was going on conan like
the next day yeah he's running his set
and i remember going after him and like
looking at like really like looking at
yes and being like what you're standing
this guy is on tv tomorrow yes and i
went on after him and i went like they
just had the best guy on the show and
now the worst guy what and i remember
coming off stage and this guy artie
januario who only started a month before
me like why did you why would you do
that
like he didn't just say don't do that he
made me answer like why would you do
that right and i was like wow because
i'm like i'm new and i suck and he's
good and he's like why would you say
that
that's just and i was like i don't know
and he's like don't ever say that don't
tell the audience you're bad oh no
you need those every now and then you're
like i didn't know that was a bad thing
to do right so now i know it's like one
time we did uh
sac sacramento years ago it was my first
weekend on the road with derosa with
derozan i remember remember when you
both were telling me you were doing this
you featuring i'm hosting i'm a new
comic and i went up and i had a couple
jokes about at my day job my day job
whatever and you pulled me aside you're
like why would you tell them you have a
job i'm like because i have a job and
you're like
they think you're a comedian be a
comedian i was like
oh i didn't know we couldn't have a job
i said i stand by that
you buy a ticket and the guy goes up
there and he's like yeah i work at sears
you're like what am i what the [ __ ]
right i see a guy that works yeah it's
almost like you're working against
yourself yeah you gotta be like i used
to work at sears now i'm making millions
here i'm seeing at the sacramento
punchline never crossed my mind but i i
still think about that to this day when
i'm showering sac town the bay area and
back down
how was that weekend
great oh yeah it was great i remember
bjorn our manager left us and i also
remember another moment that i remember
we were mark and i was sitting in the
pool and deroza came and he's like
pulling his hair out i wonder what he's
gonna do with his life and he's like at
some point i gotta move to l.a i mean we
all do obviously i remember being like
moved to l.a
why would i move to l.a he's like we
have to don't you think yeah and then he
was also like i want to be woody allen i
was like so do i he lives in new york
uh-huh not the movies i just wanted to
have sex with my daughter
i think you guys kind of there was some
some butting heads at that point yeah
derozan i had a lot of touch but now i
think we're cool i saw him the other day
by the way derose is like amazing i love
that he did our episode and was amazing
he's great yeah he's like so good i was
really blown away so funny he's also
amazing on his podcast great
listen to but
i watch the clip i watch the clips i die
laughing and then i don't listen to it
it's all you need taste is perfect yeah
a taste of a taste tastes bud it's hard
to it's hard to commit to a comedy
podcast when you're a comedian it is
yeah it is
it's so true i i want i i don't want to
be influenced in any way i want to just
listen to news or sports i just i don't
want anything that's comedy yeah you
don't want to be fun
did we used to date this sounds familiar
there's also 5 000 of them so you're
going to listen to all of them you know
it's tough to pick yeah it's also weird
to listen to your friends on a podcast i
mean i could call you guys up on the
phone true true but i there was once you
were on fit simmons and i was alone i
was lonely somewhere and i was like oh
listen to this really yeah because if i
call you i gotta think of stuff to say
but if if it's a pot you're doing all
the work it's almost like catching up
while you're just laying there yes yeah
that's all right yeah i don't listen to
any i should i mean i literally watched
the clips and i'm like this is amazing i
don't know why i wouldn't think to
listen to the other 42 minutes but i
never have well i sat there and i
thought why i'm with a group of guys i'm
looking at my phone every time i get
bored and i sat there and i thought why
am i looking at my phone i got these
good good funny people here and i
realize it's because you don't have to
interact
interacting is work of course you know
listening is a whole thing and listening
and going right now yeah
sorry what were you talking about
exactly exactly but it's good to put
that work in it pays off and it comes
back and it's better but
the easy route is just a scroll yes
it's mindless but it's you never feel
good after no it's like the equivalent
of a one-night stand you're like what
was that right the scroll does
help you not have the awkward remote
because everybody wants a break
so it's nice because in the old days
you'll just be sitting there in silence
and you have to be like uh
what where where where'd you get the
shirt like you have to fill it in but
now it's like all right we're doing
phone time the commercial is nice so as
long as you don't overly overdo it right
right yeah but i just had that i was
just on a trip with sarah my family and
it was like
my family hangs out 24 hours a day or
whatever
18 hours a day and there's no break at
all so we're like exhausted that
physical exhaustion of just being on all
day and then you need some booze to
soften a little yeah but you don't do
that they're all boozed up yeah is that
weird that they're drinking and you just
don't do that uh sorry for just belching
on the
microphone
apologize here um
no not really not anymore i mean that's
the most triggering for me is family
because it's like that's how they
connect and they're drinking and it's
obviously the stress of family so it
would be nice
but um no not really it's the same my my
ladies from boston and all they do
thanksgiving christmas easter whatever
it is i'll go visit and it's just 10 a.m
somebody cracks that first beer and then
they go oh okay and now they're all
drinking and i will take walks because i
need a break i need a breather and
they're like give me [ __ ] about the
walks they're like what are you doing
out there who are you talking to who you
walking with i'm like i'm just taking a
walk they're like why are you taking a
walk and they kind of take it personally
and i'm like no it's i'm a weirdo and
and i imagine it's the same way yeah no
sarah hates it because like her family
is so different than my family her
family you hang out for like two hours
and you talk about like
south african politics like her mother's
like the smartest person on the planet
they're literally like having an
in-depth discussion of like 1300s
west african politics and i'm like i'm
like costanza i'm like what about sports
that's how i feel like i'm just dying
but then they all go off into their
separate things we'll go for a bike ride
and a run everyone goes to their own
room and watches their own tv and then
they like reconvene my family there's no
intellectual conversation whatsoever but
it's it's all day long ah that would
kill me as a kid yeah she's
dying but i'm like that too
now when we go on hangs you'll see i'll
be like wait where the [ __ ] where's sam
why is sam writing why isn't he sitting
here talking about that right
with sacramento we did that you're like
i noticed you never write i'm like we're
hanging out
why would i write i'm a big alone time
yeah i like to i like to kind of have a
routine and uh wake up and
make my coffee and to sit at the
computer and and go through the paper
and and try to come up with premises i i
ti
hanging too much stresses me out i get
it i'm the same way i'm that way but
then when you're with family that's why
right now i feel like
[ __ ] if you're frightened because i'm
like i've just been hanging for like and
then before that i was on vacation
sharing a house with a family so i've
been like
with people close quarters for like 11
days and i was like come straight to a
podcast yeah believe me i don't want to
be here
now that i'm here it's great it is fun
you always dread to do the thing but
then once you're at the thing it's
usually that's all of life that's all
you got to get over that hump that's
what i'm saying with the phone put it
down and there's that hump of
awkwardness but you get over it it's
better hump of awkwardness that's the
stupid high school story
can we talk about your movie coming out
yeah let's talk about it it's coming
it's coming soon i'm i'm proud of you
and i'm excited to see it man oh thanks
it might suck um i watch it and i'm like
oh god
why
well it's like there's sentimental
things and i'm like oh we just [ __ ]
cause we have so many cynical comedy
fans they're gonna watch it like look at
them pretending to cry what a [ __ ]
and you know you've trashed so many
movies that it could come back to you
well that's the problem i have to wipe
my entire movie podcast than half of our
podcast yeah i'm like a con i'm like i'm
on the record robert redford's a piece
of [ __ ] right sucks i he's dog [ __ ] i
stand by it but now i'm in a movie and
uh do you you don't like redford i think
he's bad i think he's actually bad i
think that he's
overrated it's so high he's this he's
just not as good he's just outclassed by
he's no paul newman he's just a movie
yeah he's like a handsome guy he's
relatively flat and everyone's like well
what about the sting and it's like the
sting is great
one of the best scripts ever he's got
newman there
and it's a beautiful
movie
uh same with butch cassidy yeah but he's
just redford he's not great i shouldn't
say he's bad it's just funny to say he's
such sure but he's very i watched the
one on the boat it's just him i think we
got a redford fan here that is bad i
think one of the boat is bad
it looks it looked awful it's really
really bad it was like how about
castaway with an older guy
he just doesn't have range he's not a
rangeful actor right i think all the
president's men is [ __ ] boring
it was a little boring it's a it's just
like it's a slow movie for the 70s which
means it's really [ __ ] slow yeah but
i just like redford
obviously he's better than me i suck i'm
the my movie sucks but rob radford
he doesn't have to do that now that
you're a filmmaker he doesn't have that
performance i mean he doesn't like
pacino you watch dog day and the
godfather movies you're like i don't
care what he's doing is top five i don't
same here i don't care what he does with
spiky hair and the yelling and the
[ __ ] like
whatever
you can do all that he's got dog day and
he's got the two godfather movies and
cruising is also great and i mean the
movie's not great
he's just he's just so great in those
and like obviously de niro and uh paul
newman and nicholson and brandon hoffman
so redford gets involved in this class
because he's such a movie guy right
interesting and he's just he's very flat
he's very robert redford i think the
same way about clooney what about him oh
i'm a clooney fan what about his
director it's embarrassing because the
river runs
i think is solid
um
i think he directed a river runs through
yeah he's directed some stuff he's
directed uh a couple other things i
think he's good at that i mean okay
who what you you have a lot of
controversial movie takes you have like
you hate uh you hate fight club i don't
hate it but i think it's very silly i
think if you watched it more recently
you'd be like this is pretty silly it's
pretty cool though too
it's got some cool things it's pretty
ridiculous and a lot of it doesn't make
sense the twist does not quite make
sense what that he's actually tyler yeah
there's like moments where they're both
there and reacting people are reacting
to both aha people in a way oh
interesting i can't explain it properly
right now but
because i haven't watched it enough but
it doesn't quite make sense it's not
great and i think it's like
this bro [ __ ] jerk off to it like
that's that's me right there
it doesn't really add up or make much
sense what what are other like hot movie
takes
i don't know i don't have as many as uh
you want here i get i get a lot of heat
for being like a piece of [ __ ] guy who
hates everything but i like
people always give me [ __ ] on our pocket
they're like you just want to be
contrarian i'm like my favorite artists
are pearl jam and bruce springsteen my
favorite movies goodfellas and forrest
gump i'm like forrest gump good fellas
casino i mean i mean you know apollo 13.
i'm not exactly schindler's list these
are pretty like tom petty standard great
movies yeah i'm like the stones i'm a
die-hard i'm like i'm not some [ __ ]
who's like i only like bad brains well
the thing was the thing that triggers
people is the sopranos that triggers me
he hates the soprano that triggers me
well but i feel like i've made cases
that i've gotten people to give in a
little bit go home a few bars give us
well we've talked about it one i'll tell
him the show is
sit commie like there's like sit-commie
jokes there's joke jokes which i don't
care for uh-huh like set up punch like i
hate the comedian i hate jokes you can
feel the worst well i don't like it
honest what's supposed to be a gritty
[ __ ] show but i've talked about this
in so many places and i get so much hate
so i feel like everyone can hear this
somewhere else but my main thing is
stevie van zandt
and paulie walnuts are cartoon
characters right take you out of it
ridiculous
and i cannot i can't abide i can't
you can't
you people put it with like goodfellas
and the godfather and [ __ ] i don't do
that i put it above whoa i mean
but this is what i have to say this is
where i have to make a compromise with
people i don't care for the medium i
don't i'm not a tv guy you're not i
don't like tv i don't like you at least
give that gandolfini is incredible he's
great all right
but like stevie van zandt who also
happens to be the guitarist in my
favorite band which takes away yeah
norton had a great line he'd be like if
tony iomi however you say his name from
[ __ ] black sabbath like walked into
like seinfeld and was like
it takes you out of it first of all he's
a very famous guitarist and a very
favorite man but he's wearing like a
rubber wig
and he's like hey
i mean he's he's really you can admit
that he's silly he's over the top he's
over the top he has moments where he's
where he's heavy and he's good in it
though so he's over the top and then
paulie walnuts who's just like oh yeah
then i'm like
hilarious i think he's incredible
paulie's in a lot of mob movies but it's
over broadway one of my favorite
comedies of all time oh great but these
are straight up comedies yeah yeah so
it's different tonally it's different
sure and
uh i haven't watched all the episodes
whenever we watch the one on the podcast
where like chris like sits on a dog and
he's supposed to be like a junkie
he doesn't look junky and then there's
this a straight up vaudevillian comedy
scene in it so i don't understand the
intervention but good fellas
it's hilarious but but goodfellas is
funny because it's so genuine that's
what makes it situational so real and
it's so funny funny how like exactly
it's just so pitch perfect that it makes
it hilarious and then i think you're
like going for
joke jokes but i haven't watched the
whole show and obviously i'm a piece of
[ __ ] because i got three people ever
that have agreed with me on this one wow
really
yeah and no other hot takes like you you
hate you hate seven you hate fight club
i don't hate them i just think they're
very silly are you a david fincher fan
though
i like zodiac zodiac zodiac is one of my
favorite social networks ever social
network i don't love i think it's
overrated and also like these movies
that are based on like real things and
just take liberties i find so
ridiculous but zuckerberg does seem like
a terrible person at least oh certainly
yeah so at least if you're gonna like
make someone seem shitty at least it's a
dude who seems shitty yeah it's not as
bad as like rudy that's like the worst
one ever yeah the coach dan duvine you
ever hear that story uh they they wanted
to make him like the heavy they needed
like a bad guy so they made him and they
called and they told him like we're
gonna make you a little bit more
negative and less likeable and he's like
oh okay
and then they made the scene where
everyone turns in their jerseys and he's
like refusing to let rudy play and he's
like that's not even that's i made him
play i made him that was me i was the
head coach that's frustrating that never
happened and then even the scene the end
when there's like don't put them in like
the coordinator throws it in he's like i
put him in i i did that with movies you
need an arc you need bad guys so they
take liberties in these stories i mean
mark and i were talking about the show
winning time on hbo which i like the
show
but they make jerry west they portray
him in such a [ __ ] up way they make a
lot of his takes just wrong and i'm like
that's one of the great basketball
geniuses of all time right the guy
literally traded for kobe right the guy
traded valadi kobe he signed 17 year old
kobe i know and he signed shaq he he
knew kobe was going to be a jordan level
player he
all the genius moves he made and like i
feel like every episode he's like we got
to get elgin baylor to be coach i'm like
show one of the smart moves he made he's
such a basketball genius he's throwing
chairs through windows he's like the
angry guy that's it that's all he's
angry because he was a psycho competitor
and then you see him interviewed in real
life and you're like he's like a
soft-spoken warm man yeah with
depression who's like got a dark side he
own he owns you know but guys like dan
devine the coach he has to live the rest
of his life people being like you piece
of [ __ ] he should have played that
five-foot guy
and he's like i did that was me what are
you talking about they should make a
sandusky movie where he's just like
really cool
he took some liberties he's handing out
sponges in the shower he's nice he's
giving out towels
um but yeah i love the godfather i love
dog day afternoon i love you know die
day afternoon's a top five movie of all
time to me but it's most it's day
afternoon is like it's funny it's
[ __ ] ahead of its time the way they
deal with that uh translation
is like incredibly ahead of its time oh
yeah it's
got so many different like modes where
like you laugh in one minute you're
[ __ ] sad for them the next day and
you feel for the guy who's robbing a
bank no it's like magical it's like one
of the best movies ever it's top five
without question to me yeah but what's
great also the best new york movie ever
oh yeah attica that's a little insane
but you don't think so
no wait hold on i want to hear what well
what i'm just going to say is i like
what i like about you is you get berated
with all these takes of yours and these
opinions of yours and you stick with it
i would have caved
a year and a half ago like all right i
watched sopranos again it's good just so
you leave me alone yeah but you hang in
there i mean i now at this point i'd
have to lean into it yeah
yeah people get very upset the sopranos
thing is like serious business people
don't bother me for sure
i mean i can't believe i have a smart
hilarious friend who thinks that
sopranos is bad it's not that again i
had to change my thing i just don't care
for tv i hate episodic i hate that it's
like okay so eight more years of this
just give me two hours three hours solve
the problem is it because you hate fat
is it because there's like a movie it's
like you're in and out it's every scene
counts whereas in there there's have you
seen his ex it's just
it's just so uh
like put on it's like they so i can feel
the writing i can feel the writer's room
i can feel them being like we need an
issue okay what's today's problem let's
come up with a problem we need an ark
and okay let's punch it up you punch it
up like i can feel the i can see the
punch-up that's a joke again these two
characters are just so [ __ ]
ridiculously over the top that it takes
me out of the whole thing i'm like what
what is the tone of the show
it's so silly to me but tv in general
like i started watching ozarks yeah and
i love jason bateman i think he's like
fantastic great and i was like this show
is great
but i got five episodes in and i'm like
so it's gonna keep being that we solve
it and then a new thing props up and
then i'm like there's four more seasons
of this so every day it's like this is
an impossibility and then we don't solve
it but it's tv that's the only format
you can do with tv because you have to
have multiple seasons and make more
money so i think tv format is the
problem well hilarious it's a hilarious
critique of tv oh so there's just going
to be more but that's the thing is but
that's exactly the point it's like they
have to come up with stuff right
they came up with a story yeah here's
the story this is a story about
how my life got flipped upside down
whatever you know what i mean you're
like we're gonna tell a story about you
know two guys robbing a bank and one
guy's robbing a bank for his to raise
money for his wife to have a [ __ ] uh
sex whatever and okay and the cops are
gonna come and that's the resolution
soprano tv they're like okay here's a
story and it's ten episodes got it that
was great we're selling merch
come up with 10 more stories yeah [ __ ]
okay let's maybe what if he gets an
intervention wouldn't it be funny if
he's on heroin yeah just because we need
something we need material yeah that's
why canadians suck after 20 years
we're all heading that way by the way
yeah it's all downhill baby what uh are
there tv shows that you like i mean
obviously seinfeld curb right comedy is
a little bit different but not many
seinfeld i think is like this is the
thing people again people are like you
just contrarian i'm like i think
seinfeld's the best thing ever of all
time although i do think the first two
and last two seasons are horrendous
there you go it's another controversial
horrendous not horrendous but they're
not the first just they're finding it
they're finding their footing they don't
know what the hell they're doing yet and
then the last one's larry david leaves
so it gets super cartoony seasons eight
and nine i have real issues with i just
i love it but i hate it how about like
old school simpsons
simpsons i love too like i think like
seasons three through eight are like
unbelievable but again you can agree
that it flipped so yeah
i mean i don't think it's easy to
maintain a level of excellence for 33
seasons yes pretty tough but that's a
lot of these things it's like just call
it quits that was great
yeah the office british you're in you're
out everybody loved it but i love the
british i love the american office i
hate the last four the first four
seasons of america once once the love
interests get together it's always kind
of yeah it's always the will they won't
they once it's gone you're kind of like
well i hate jim pam but steve carell i
think might be like top five funniest
people oh he's just every second
and he's magical too i mean they're like
the guy who plays dwight
oh yeah yeah oh rain will i
misunderstood he's phenomenal yeah he's
good
um i love curb
yeah there's a lot of bad curve but i
love curb cheers i love there's a lot of
bad cheers but i love cheers
pretty mainstream
i know that's what i said i'm like i'm
like a basic [ __ ] i don't know what
you're talking about you know the guy's
got starbucks and new balance i know
that's what i'm saying all right
i'm not some i just have a couple takes
we're going to cheesecake factory after
this i love the cheesecake i got gift
cards in my backpack what uh cheesecake
rules so but you're worried about the
movie i've heard it's great i've heard
oh thanks i think it's good i am
it's hard because you get so [ __ ] up
you know how it is it's like watching
your own stuff you're like it's not even
like watching you because at least in
stand up you're like they're it's
killing
i don't give a [ __ ] the baby is like uh
you're not getting an honest opinion
really yeah um and it's tough with a
movie because you don't get multiple
tries with stand-up like a bit can work
out over five months this is like here
it is it's done we hope
it's like that side belting it's like
you watch a bad movie it's an hour and a
half you're in a bad movie it's like a
year and a half right
right um but i think it's pretty good i
think it'll resonate it's not
particularly funny we took out a lot of
the comedy there's not a lot of hilarity
in it it's pretty
uh dramatic but i think it's fun i think
the music is great
i think the act the people that play my
parents are like amazing really really
like the guy that plays my dad is like
unbelievable so were you and and
forgive me if i'm i'm prying but were
you back there with the headphones on
the director's chair the video village
you know with the big bull horn and the
beret going cut it redo it turn it
around you know
cut the tape whatever check the gate all
that [ __ ] lock it up um i was doing a
lot of stuff as a bit i'm doing it i did
it the way you were doing it which was
fun i had a great time i kept well it
was funny because i'd be like check the
gate yeah and then louie's like we
should actually check the game
um but it was fun to use all my uh film
school [ __ ] yes but i never used
the clipboard down what are you doing
out there i need emotion god there were
times like that it was exciting because
i mean i'm an executive producer writer
so there was stuff like that but like
with the scenes that i wasn't in i did
have the headset which was really fun
and we were watching on video village
which was really exciting wow that was
like the funnest part is
not being in it because
you're like watching it and they're the
the people playing my parents those are
the scenes that i'm not in
are like having the sea and you're like
punching each other i mean it is magical
because you have it with stand up where
you write a bit and then you do it and
it works which is like special but a
movie it's like louie and i were sitting
saying then he says this what if he says
that yeah and this will happen and then
somebody's acting it out and they're
nailing it and you're like oh my god
and you can't make noise you're
literally like we're doing this wow and
then you say cut and you're like
unbelievable movie magic it was magical
and they're unbelievable they're so good
um i'm worried i stink and um
i just wanted to make sense to people
but i think it does everyone's been
really complimentary so we'll see yeah i
bet it's great man oh thanks yeah i
think you'll like it i think it's up
your uh [ __ ]
there you go i hope so yeah let's i mean
this therapy this
an allen character in there and bobby
kelly is plays the guy he's great
does louis play allen louie plays my
therapist wow and he's great you forget
how good of an actor louie is he's
really great yeah i was watching uh
american hustle on a flight recently and
i was just cracking i forgot louie's in
it oh that's right cracking up you know
those scenes with louie and bradley
cooper are [ __ ] hilarious he had a
run of a couple big big blockbusters
yeah
that was a solid movie some woody allen
movie too
yeah he was in um the big one the one
that won an academy award there yeah i
can't think of the name right now blue
blue jasmine blue jasmine yeah yeah oh
god holy [ __ ] yeah yeah that was good um
so yeah he's great and um sarah's in it
she's great a lot of it's like very
real and like it's it's raw it's a
little nerve-wracking because my family
the family stuff makes you nervous
yeah
because there's a scene where i like
snap on to my family and i'm like you
all suck you're pieces of [ __ ] idiots
but it's not
my family but it looks
like my family it's literally about like
a new york guy who goes to maine for the
fourth of july every year and it's sober
right um oh boy a little on the nose
it's been on the note but you you know
you write what you know but uh so but
the family is not like in the movie the
mother's like a sociopath my mother's
very sweet great mom
yeah deb um so
there's that too so it's nerve-wracking
and it's going to be seen by a lot of
people it's you know it's scary to put
your [ __ ] out there it is the whole
thing out in the ch out the cheese is
out in the wind i mean that's it they
get to pick and poke and this sucked and
that sucked or i like that i mean that's
that's very ballsy and very vulnerable
it's very scary and uh also it's like
who's this then you just wipe with
people that are like who is this guy
making a movie let's look into him
mark and i you know that's the whole
talking about [ __ ] kids for 25
minutes and come in my face and you know
eating my dad's ass that's our best
stuff and they're gonna be like what the
hell is wrong with these guys i know so
that is a little scary also but you
gotta live i think it's a good movie i
think it'll resonate and i think it's
the kind of movie i like it's like
that's mark's response to [ __ ] kids
you gotta live you gotta live damn it
well i forget tight hole it's weird
because you know i have nieces and
nephews i go my buddy derek i hang out
with his kids and like you know they're
five and nine and i'm like running
around wrestling people like
you the guy that says ends your podcast
with the [ __ ] kid i know what's going
on here and you're like well i'm kidding
of course yeah i forget sometimes like i
made a jelaine maxwell joke at the
dinner table and my niece is like who's
jalane max now my sister has to explain
it to her and i'm like oh god i stink
yeah
that sounds i gotta learn something she
said it in a good way she said you know
how how you know you have a family who
loves you very much and she goes yeah
she's like well she took uh she she
prayed on people who didn't have that i
was like that's a pretty good joke wow
that's a pretty good that's good
parenting yeah very good parenting great
parent jesus i mean just lane also has
good experience with children but yeah
that's tough what a parent is hard but i
mean dude you have all these awesome
things coming out
the movie you have a stand-up special on
youtube yeah especially comes out soon i
don't know when this comes out but april
29th there
oh that's what's out right now okay
great it's been out for a month i hope
you've watched it oh [ __ ] uh it came out
april 29th it's out april 29th it's out
now go
watch it there you go
i was there at the tape and it was it
was an incredible special yeah it was
really fun it was great i'm excited i
think it was good but i gotta say i
haven't watched it because they sent it
to me and i watched like 20 minutes and
i just get sick to my stomach and i was
like it's perfect it gets harder and
harder to edit your own [ __ ] yeah i go
crazy i'm kind of like can someone else
just do this that's what i'm just crazy
i don't want to deal with it no i can't
so i'm like
[ __ ] the night it comes out i might be
like what the [ __ ] but it's a catch-22
because you want it to be perfect and
your your vision but you also can't
watch it so you got to just suck it up
and watch it yeah because you don't want
them to make some weird edit that you
weren't approving of well at least with
stand up i can be like the show went
well so as long as it looks like the
show yeah it'll be pretty good little
things bug me though and special like
sometimes i'll do like the side shot too
much and i'm like who is this for right
it's like a [ __ ] mug shot no one
wants to i want dead on that's the
obvious yeah i think the more
i think people we've talked about this a
bit before but the more innovative you
try to get with the special the worse it
gets yeah i really think stand-up that's
what's so great about stand-up is
it's just stand-up it's just just
present it that's the show wrong you
don't want questions tarantino directing
a stand-up special no we don't need i
mean maybe he would know how to just do
it in a minimalist way but like
you want
any time that you notice the direction
in the comments
it's taken away from the material that's
how i feel the director should be like a
referee in a sporting event yeah you
only notice it if it's you like hey what
the [ __ ]
like you should just be like that was
great yeah good point you know no one's
like the patriots ram super bowl those
refs really nailed it the first one the
second one was [ __ ] i think uh chris
rock kind of [ __ ] himself with that uh
what was that special we did three
cities
i can't remember the name of it it was
never scared kill the messenger
messenger yeah but it was like it might
have been great material but it was i'm
in johannesburg i'm in harlem i'm in
whatever and you're like ah
i'm i'm off this is off yeah i'm not
focusing on that we tried a new thing i
mean i respect them for trying i heard
rocks say once the seller he goes every
stand-up special should be like an
iphone like i want a new feature and i'm
like that's how he approaches it
i disagree too but that's his approach i
mean it's like sure i mean he's he's not
just original with his stand-up he's
original with the you know how it's uh
you know gonna be seen so i i appreciate
that but you know
uh i i thought tambourine was was more
my speed you know i didn't know the
other one i just think a stand-up
special should be a presentation of the
stand-up yeah so it should be
bare bones that's how i felt
doing this i just did the second one at
the same venue
because i'm like and then this is a big
giant stupid sign but i'm like but the
material is what makes it different it's
kind of like the beatles
they have three different singers four
different singers but you know it's the
beatles because it sounds like the
beatles aha i don't know that's a
perfect analogy but no one's like who
the [ __ ] is this yeah who's this guy
singing i never heard of this guy true
that's another beetle
yeah that's a good point i'm i'm with
you on the bare bones i think it's like
you work so hard to make these jokes
land and
make them you know
work in every single state that's really
like how you tour we're like this better
joke and this joke better work in like
florida ohio san francisco you know and
then if someone tries to do too much
with the taping you're just kind of like
you ruined two years of my life
i just watched a later office episode
american office and like they're doing
like these crazy the cuts are too fast
and they're like zooming on every shot
and i'm like i'm like discombobulated
yeah exactly it's jokes just give me the
jokes that's what i'm saying i don't
want paul greengrass directing my next
special
yeah and i always say uh we i think we
say this stand up is the best is
listening like you're in a long car ride
and you're just hearing the audio you
are sucked in and i think with a special
it should be
yeah bare bones as you say because the
the audio is really what's important
that's how i got into stand up is albums
is like you know chris rock's you know
roll with the new chris rock's you know
his albums the eddie murphy albums the
mitch hedberg david tells oh yeah those
were albums i'm like this makes me and
you're just listening and you're like
this is
it's almost like the equivalent of like
people like i listen to baseball games
you know right there's a beauty to that
i love listening to baseball but i think
what so great about albums
is when you're watching a special this
is what's so depressing about comedy
specials is there's nothing that it
can't come anywhere close it's at least
30 percent worse than the actual live
yes show easily but with audio you're in
the audience because there's no visual
so you're just that you close your eyes
and you're in the audience you're
getting it the same way they are you're
just getting the audio and you're
laughing with the audience but on visual
you can see that you're outside the room
so you're watching people watch a
special like there is a divide where
there's not a divide with audio if that
makes sense i get it i get it it taps in
more with audio you're right especially
with the video too you're like look at
the outfit look at the hot girl in the
front row what's that thing is that
brick what is that molding what is that
yeah you're off we're already seeing
other [ __ ] and it's distracting and
nothing more bad for comedy than
distractions yeah too bad spotify
removed all their [ __ ]
yeah they weren't paying us those guns
can you you can still listen though i'm
an apple music guy so i've never used
spotify but you can also still buy the
album and download it to your phone
right yeah go back to buying record if
you're listening at home
it'd be nice buy some albums please we
all have six
don't you miss consuming i had this
conversation in uh the worst person in
the world which is an amazing movie just
saw it but they you i miss consuming
thing like now like band of horses is
the first band i got into post
holding a cd
like i used to consume the lyrics the
producer the band i knew every band yes
band of horses one of my favorite bands
i don't even know the name of most of
the songs right because you just have it
streaming and you're like oh here's this
song yes before you'd like know the
title you'd look at the record of the cd
yeah
and just be like okay that's track one i
know that track title i know who
produced it i know who plays what on
what totally i mean i think you're i
think that just comes with you have too
much we're looking at our phone we're
looking at this we got too much going on
where before he'd hold a record and read
the back you'd look at the art you'd
unfold it i used to work at blockbuster
i would just stare at the movie covers
all day yeah and it was fun and then you
flip it over and you're like that's a
director he directed that too but yeah
now it's just like
give me more more and more i already
watched that who's that i don't know who
directed ozark yeah we we'd just digest
too quickly now it's like it's like the
credits start and the next thing starts
and like i'm like i want to see the
credits i hate that you can't even watch
the credits i want to see the credits i
want to know who is who yes please watch
the credits of my movie i'm all over
those credits there you go exciting but
yeah the special's out it's out right
now it's called uh this year's material
it's on youtube
and uh
it's hopefully it's got tons of
views
it'll get there we'll see i'm a little
nervous because uh it's gonna be great
well because the last one was on comedy
central's youtube which has two million
whatever you call it
i feel like i'm 150 years old i'm like
followers subscribers people peeps it's
crazy right and i have numbers 20 000 or
something like that so hopefully people
watch it it'll build if it's good it's
good that's the beauty of youtube if the
it's the closest we get to a meritocracy
but it's good but it doesn't but this is
where it's tricky though because it's
not just good it's good because you have
to get into the algorithm sure it can be
great and not make it in like the comedy
central one and you just will have to do
your
you have to do a [ __ ] million
podcasts now i know that's how it goes
it's political seeing you guys no i feel
the same way do i tell mark every week
i'm like man i'm podcasted out i want to
wake up and just write jokes and just
kind of take walks and do that [ __ ] yeah
but like the amount of talking we have
to do now is like
it's bad for art it's okay and it's bad
for your career like colin says it he's
like we're living he's like it's the
funniest thing of all time that like
we're living in a time where you can get
ruined for anything you say and every
comedian literally records everything he
says i know hopefully it dilutes it a
little bit you know yeah i guess yeah
there's enough horrible [ __ ] being said
that it's hard to keep up that's our
only hope is like yeah but i've had like
i've said that like eight hours worth of
saying that
i've said it a million times that's all
right
i didn't slip up that's like who i am
yeah
well the problem is when
it's not just hey he said this it's when
you get something and then they go hey
this guy said this
like a shane gillis right you get an snl
nobody nobody cared about the horrible
[ __ ] he said before that but when you
get the snl they're like now we got you
right that light just burned out
geez good effect i swear to god it was
wasn't that odd it was a piece i don't
know okay it's not like super
illuminating so it's hard to know it's
like the godfather too you're right
though i mean i do think
we might be drunk and sponsored by
better help online therapy relationships
take work a lot of us will drop anything
to go help someone we care about we'll
go out of our way to treat other people
well but how often do we give ourselves
the same treatment for me
working out or buying some new sneakers
is an investment in myself this month
better help online therapy wants to
remind you to take care of your most
important relationship the one you have
with yourself we're in therapy we go to
the same guy it's necessary clean out
the garbage your head has all these
horrible thoughts
splicing your childhood traumatic
experiences you're a wreck you're a mess
you need therapy get out the garbage
whether it's hitting the gym making time
for a haircut or even trying therapy
you're your greatest asset so invest
time and effort into yourself like you
do for other people tell them how better
help is online therapy that offers video
phone and even live chat sessions with
your therapist so you don't have to see
anyone on camera if you don't want to
maybe you got a weird boil on your face
or something you're weird you know you
don't want to see that you're all set
yep it's much more affordable than
in-person therapy and you can be matched
with a therapist in under 48 hours give
it a try and see why over 2 million
people have used better help online
therapy we might be drunk is sponsored
by better help and listeners get 10 off
their first month at
betterhelp.com drunk that's
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p-com
drunk
you got to do this it's it's therapy
very important take care of yourself
it's going to change your life here here
bowl
frozen concentrated orange juice futures
contracts
with all the jargon
with all the jargon flying around it can
be hard to figure out how to start
investing right mark
you got that right i'm clueless and i
need help
getting your money right is easier with
sofi the first investing platform to
offer stocks etfs automated investing
and cryptocurrency two all in one app i
mean mark that we need help
we need help with this finally
yeah this is this is heavy stuff and uh
everybody's getting into it but us we're
missing out so this is really good
have you done crypto before or no
i have and i i never know what i'm doing
i always buy the wrong thing i need a
friend to help me and take and hold my
hand so this this is for me
oh i mean this this is holding your hand
dude whether you're eager to start
investing or you already know the ropes
so far has your back no commissions on
trading stocks and etfs and no account
fees or hidden fees
yeah their complimentary financial
planners are ready to help with any
questions whether you're stuck on where
to start or need help deciding what to
do next i mean this is this is for us
safe for retirement with traditional
roth and sep iras cut through the jargon
and make it easier
investing with sofi visit sofi.com drunk
that's
sofi.com drunk and learn how you can win
up to a thousand dollars in stock when
you open an account brokerage and active
investing products offered through
shopify securities llc member
finra sipc
you guys are the best
give it a shot can't wait i'm gonna sign
up today
so far
hey folks we might be drunk is brought
to you by manscaped oh yeah set your
first new year's resolution
with good intentions enjoying the four
million men worldwide who trust manscape
with our exclusive offer go to
manscape.com and use promo code drunk
for 20 off plus free
shipping holy hell
i love manscape i use the ball wash i
shave with the uh the lawn mower it's
good stuff it gets it in tight i keep it
in my travel bag i just whatever i need
it it's all there you got the crop
preserver crop reviver uh you got the
lawnmower 4.0 it's got a light on it for
christ 6. i love this thing they love it
they even uh they sh they have a travel
bag i still use boxer briefs are great
and uh the ultra premium body wash is
great for manscaped love manskip i just
use their shampoo and conditioner if i'm
being honest yeah yeah oh yeah i use it
today that's where this [ __ ] load of
bird's nest came from but yeah get it
get on it folks
yeah i got some of that shampoo in my in
my uh shower too hey whether your
resolution is to work out more or to
travel to new places be sure to travel
to manscape.com
for our exclusive offer of 20 off plus
free shipping with the code drunk that's
20 off and free shipping with the code
drunk at manscape.com
one last time one last time sorry i've
been drinking
20 off with free shipping at
manscape.com use the code drunk it's the
new year no pubes in 2022
with manscaped support the show and get
20 off and free shipping with the code
drunk at manscape.com hell yeah get on
it man and look better and smell better
i do think no one really cares unless
they're they're taking something from
you it's just kind of [ __ ] up i mean
like for whatever reason the snl vetting
process is like joining the cia so
that's that's definitely made it
interesting where they're just like
yeah you can't i mean you're not running
for [ __ ] office you're trying to do
impressions on a weekly show i don't
know when this became yeah i know you
find the outrage a little disingenuous
dude
that's a pretty bold take on my part
yeah that's not the same thing so snl
just had a like a gilbert godfrey
tribute i'm like do you remember what
he's
he said horrible [ __ ] like you would
never have him on now that's the irony i
know oh yeah we always talk about that
it's like there's a street named after
george carlin i'm like he's called black
people the n word multiple times
there's a street in utah call malone
whatever boulevard and you're like this
guy [ __ ] impregnated a 13 year old is
that right oh yeah wow
you should have two streets
holy [ __ ]
but yeah the movie's coming out it's
gonna be ended we're gonna have a big
premiere end of june and uh which is
like a month away and uh and then it'll
be out in theaters in july i can't wait
man yeah it's gonna be big please go see
it theaters theaters i'm gonna be on the
big screen i'm like the lead in a big
screen film wow it's gonna kill me i'm
gonna i'm gonna be like [ __ ] uh river
phoenix outside the viper room we should
go and do a full paul rubens in there
yeah yeah i want to be that guy who like
throws off my hat and i'm like it's me
yeah
let's go fred willard merrill i'm gonna
drop a name meryl streep who's a friend
of mine she said uh she's like you go to
the premiere and everyone gives you a
standing o and says you're the greatest
and you're gonna win an oscar and we
love you she's like but that's not a
real you have to go see the movie at the
theater yeah that's when you get the
real kick in the [ __ ] that's tough
because you're sitting there and you
watch people like get up and leave or
sound chatting that sounds just like
merrell man i know it too
i meant the part of the cook and the
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
i was paraphrasing
but that's what you i think they all do
that they'll put on hats and you know
fake mustaches and whatever and then
go
and they'll watch the movie and you see
people just going like it
yeah
that would be tough i saw the master on
in the theaters the pt anderson and
a guy got out it was like two black
people got up the scene where they're
all dancing naked and the guy was like
man [ __ ] this [ __ ] i got up and walked
out and then like a half an hour later
just an old white guy in front of us he
got up and walked out and i'm like wow
boy if they were sitting here they'd be
like oh geez i saw a couple black people
leave jojo rabbit they were like this
sucks [ __ ] this oh i love that movie
yeah it wasn't for them
you didn't like it well
i've talked about this on a lot of
podcasts but the quote at the end i find
so like i feel like
i know this is like maybe woke or
whatever but i'm like
they made a movie where like the nazis
are like sweet and innocuous i'm like
what is this
they're like kind of cute nazis and then
the quote at the end
is kind of insane i don't remember
what's the quote i gotta find i gotta
pull it up oh you have a pretty good
point
yeah jojo
i'm very sensitive towards uh
anti-semitism i don't i'm like i'm like
a closet jew i'm okay with it sure um
let everything happen to you beauty and
terror just keep going no feeling is
fine oh that bugs me actually about a
holocaust movement let it happen to you
they're like hey just be cool man submit
dude great quote get on the train i
think it's a a sweet quote but it's the
end of a movie about the holidays you're
like
cool man i'm like good i don't remember
that quote i don't know why there wasn't
i loved it
i think he's awesome i didn't uh
that that quote bugs me but no i did
enjoy the movie a lot and i thought he
was hilarious as hitler i know that was
like really funny no there was something
there was some good stuff there was
stuff i liked and it was sweet it moved
me but i did not
i don't remember that quote that bugs me
a little wow let it happen folks but
that was one of my favorite movies of
that year for sure i think he's just an
awesome filmmaker his movie about the
vampires you remember that one yeah yeah
dude that was funny as hell yeah he's
great i did energy vampire they suck
your energy that's so good he's so good
um yeah very good but yeah i liked that
movie i didn't love it yeah uh then
nothing worse though like you talk about
going to the theaters with the mustache
and everything nothing worse than an
insult where they're not directing it at
you because it means they meant it yes i
was at the com i've told this before i
was at the comedy works opening for
schumer sold out she's killing the
hottest crowd pete holmes at a guest set
killed killed he just happened to be in
town for some reason i was the middle i
did okay schumer was killing and i go
take a [ __ ] in the stall and i heard
guys washing their hands going that tall
guy that goofy guy [ __ ] hilarious and
the other guy was i know what schumer's
really funny she's killing and one of
them goes what do you think about the
middle guy and they were like oof
oh he sucked
and i'm [ __ ] my my clothes are on my
pants around my ankles and i was like i
thought he was pretty good
they were like no no they like doubled
down how about a green room bathroom for
that occasion
reminds me of two stories one
i mean any henry phillips story i just
start laughing before i can even get to
it because he's just the funniest guy
but he has one he plays guitar he's the
best yeah punching the clown incredible
yeah the clown is the best movie about
comedy ever he's also has one punching
henry which i'm in
and uh he's playing the guitar and in
between songs he sees like an old couple
in the front row and she leans over and
goes i hate this guy
it's the same things like you can't get
mad she's just totally genuine um also
have you talked to ronan about his story
in uh switzerland no yeah he told me
this with daniel simonson yeah adrian
it's bru you want you tell it him and
daniel they do the last show of the tour
they're on tour with louie in europe for
like six weeks and it's just like
arduous all over europe 12 countries in
six weeks whatever and it's the last
night they do the show they go to the
diner after and it's
adrian ronan and daniel simonson at the
diner and they realize there's a group
of women
from the show at the booth behind them
and they just go through the whole show
and they talk about how louis is a
genius oh wow they're literally like the
fat girl sucks he's like the guy with
the accent stinks
and then they go to like run on they're
just like he kept yelling he was so loud
and they called him the jew they're like
the jew
the jew was too fat he stinks and they
just have to sit there and listen to the
whole thing and then they're like all
right let's slunk out of here yeah and
ronan gets up and he just hears like a
crash and he looks down it's like a
cartoon it sounds made up he looks over
and simonson is laying on the ground
like somehow he fell out and
he fell in the whole table wait what and
they like point they're like that's him
that's all of them like they're all
sitting there
and then they said you were all very
funny yeah they're like you guys
and then nate has the classic one on the
cruise the cruise ship he's on the
elevator with his hat on and there's two
people talking across him about how bad
he was
how about the comic was not knowing that
he was standing there see this this is
something a lot of i don't think a lot
of artists go through oh i remember
opening for al lubel there's probably 12
years ago he did an awful gig in like
montauk or something and uh he was great
i [ __ ] bombed and i remember being in
the bathroom and just oh same as you i
was in the i was in the stall and i just
heard a guy goes man that opener sucked
he was just and i'm just like i i'm done
peeing do i just yeah do i come out
and then i i just like [ __ ] come out
and they're just like oh hey i was like
hey
it was just like a standoff there was
nothing they didn't like take it back no
they knew i heard it yeah i would have
waited [ __ ] that nothing you can do
that's when you pull your pants out and
pretend to [ __ ] you know just to buy
some time well yeah i mean i remember
doing the joker's cruise uh
and not bragging i can't believe you did
that it was years ago it was fun
it's fun it doesn't feel very you it's
not i know it's the most fun that's why
i'm saying i'm surprised yeah i'm not
fun no but uh
but you know you're not fun and that's
nice self-awareness
that helps
i remember getting off when some lady
came up to me she goes you were the
funniest and rich boss is right there
next to me and he goes oh yeah well your
friends prettier than you
that's hilarious
best comeback yeah was she prettier
though because yeah
sure sure she was i'm sure rich was
honest
rich probably has 800 of those locked
and loaded i'm just doing this forever
he's that's what colin calls him the
king of the comeback he's so funny dude
he got me once on opie and jim i was
just i was the new guy and i zinged him
and it got nothing and there was a guest
like some writer or something and he
goes sir you like comedy ghosts i love
comedy because what do you think of mark
norman and the guy goes i've never heard
of him and i'm sitting next to the guy
and rich goes that's what i thought and
it [ __ ] killed and it crushed me i
didn't say a word the rest of the hour
wow i went home and like slept it off i
was so hurt i remember i bombed a roast
once and rich goes on right after me and
he goes
he bombs one line goes you better laugh
when i'm bringing sam back up and it
crushed
and i was like oh
but as i was leaving i was like that was
pretty [ __ ] good yeah it was good i
mean i respected it
when he did it to me he hurt his opener
at the patrice benefit
what was it it was like a month after
second he goes well they wanted that we
want to have saggit and he said over my
dead body
do you have any do you have any peeves
or wrecks or bits or anything
um well i have this i just came from the
sports weekend i was at the red sox game
and the marathon and the bruins
is this anything
i'm at the game and all these there's
like this new crop of generation of
people that don't get baseball i'm like
an old man with a spoon and there's
literally it's a 3-2 game
two bases loaded two outs like eighth
inning and there's two
they're women
just painting a picture that generalizes
two women with their back to the field
trying to start the wave and mad that no
one's getting on board they're like come
on
one
two three and i'm like the [ __ ] bases
are loaded this is it you do the wave
when it's five nothing eight nothing
seven to two when the other team's up
like we're in the middle of a rally here
[ __ ] the wave ah the wave can be fun
because baseball's long baseball is long
and there's a lot of nothing happening
yes the wave at baseball is good the
problem with this is they're trying to
make it about them right we want to
start this we want to be a wave group
but it's about you we're watching the
game here yakuz get out of here just
pick the moment do you need the moment
i've started the wave i've been the
winner i don't find a way i used to
drink
i was a wave guy and it was about me i
wanted to start the wave but i wanted
everyone to have fun too but you waited
for the right way it's got to be 5-2
the seventh and then the opposing team
is up and it's just you know whatever
this is a crucial moment and they're
like come on the wave
and i feel like i'm 100 years old there
was another moment like the red sox
pitcher had a no-hitter through four and
a third and then he gives up a base hit
and typically you'd clap they stay good
effort yeah and nobody even i don't
think everyone noticed i'm like he
retired 13 in a row damn anyways those
are my baseball pieces well baseball
yeah i'm i'm with you that you got to
applaud the performance and as for the
wave it's like sex you got to pick your
moment you can't just try to [ __ ]
somebody during like a heated moment no
i never there i disagree oh okay yeah
you [ __ ] whenever you want to [ __ ] you
try to [ __ ]
you know what you're not laughing when
you're wrong
[Laughter]
well uh yeah i'm with you man i love
the the
the perfect game the no hitter it's like
one of the last great things in sports
it's pretty too the field is pretty the
whole thing's great i love i like
baseball they don't let guys do it
anymore they pull him they pulled what's
his name after seven the no hitter yeah
that's over yeah it's a different uh
it's a different time it's a different
game
david wells to put through a perfect
game after getting shit-faced the night
before yeah there's no cooler sports
story than that that guy yes all that
[ __ ] the lsd the blow the jackpot
that guy
what's his name brown
i almost said holiday
back to the future another one of my
favorite movies yeah
i'm cool that background is good
doc ellis doc ellis that's it
that was crazy then yeah no hitter on
drugs yeah all that stuff is great like
it's a guy who doesn't watch a lot of
sports i can watch any 30 for 30 and i'm
in because it's just so interesting yeah
sports are good sports are good you got
to do it so the sports you like sports
speaking of sport how was beantown you
went to 19 different games in a in a
weekend beethoven was great i'm hoarse i
went to the bruins game saturday red sox
game sunday and then yesterday monday
well what's a month ago sorry but uh
patriots day red sox two red sox games
ruins games plus the marathon wow
patriots day in boston it's a big deal
it's you know the marathon it's marathon
monday and it's a holiday only there
it's which i didn't realize until i was
like 30 years old literally
uh maybe not literally maybe 23 years
old but it's a holiday it's like a
holiday massachusetts i thought it was
just an american holiday patriots day
you have it off you go to the marathon
you get drunk you have a party that's
how i felt about mardi gras as a kid and
you're like well i guess this is our
thing yeah and they didn't even have in
new hampshire like my cousins were like
we have school what are you talking
about
um but we go every year and uh the last
two years it was
coveted so we couldn't do it and uh my
friend bart and can't jason cantor come
and uh it's just it's just the best you
wake up at 8 30 they start drinking you
know you cook breakfast everyone you got
the news on and you have the same
conversation every year yeah imagine
running 26 miles oh my god that's crazy
my ankle would hurt my knee hurts when i
get out of bed yeah it's like literally
the same dialogue they [ __ ] themselves i
[ __ ] myself from uh drinking too much
they're they're running 26 miles yeah
i've heard of all rosie ruiz she cheated
crockpot
that should be a 30 for 30. rosie ruiz
she cheated at the marathon in 1980 what
she was she's like yo it's amazing she
cheated the new york city marathon i
said that weird new york city marathon
to qualify
and she's like took the subway what and
then she like pretended to be hilarious
yeah she pretended to be hurt and that
she like got across the finish line went
to the medical tent she qualified there
she is wait is this great i feel like i
would still lose i would just like you
know i would still show up later right
that's crazy you're saying she took the
subway during the race yeah wow that's
[ __ ] hilarious she pretended that it
was just so hard on her so this is
boston here so boston i believe she it's
hard to find the video i searched for it
but so she wins the marathon yeah and at
that time there's the watch ah don't
even pay attention so at that time
there's this guy bill rogers who's like
the greatest american runner and i think
he's a new england guy he won the boston
marathon there he is in the middle there
he won the boston marathon like four
years in a row i think that was his
third year in a row and at this
conference right here where they're
standing there she is they have the
little wreaths around yeah i don't know
if you can find the video it's a good
wreath around i have it on um
i have it on dvd
i searched and searched i couldn't find
it but um
they sit down at the press conference
and bill rogers is like the king of
running he's the runner he wins it every
year he's like our guy
and he shakes hands with her and they're
like this is the winner rosie ruiz and
he literally like looks at her body and
he does like a ah and he does like a
visual like what why because he's just
looking at her legs being like this
woman won the marathon and then he
started asking her about intervals and
her splits and she's like i don't i
don't really know what you're talking
about and he's like
no competitive runner doesn't know about
their intervals or their split that'd be
like i just ran i don't know i don't
know what my pace was
damn so there's that and then somebody
asked her about wellesley college
in wellesley massachusetts it's an
all-girls school and they the whole
school comes up and goes crazy for the
first woman because it's like it's a
woman in school and they asked like how
did you feel about running through
wellesley and she was like that was cool
[Laughter]
did you feel anything she's like yeah i
felt good
and they were like this is really weird
because there was like there would have
been 30 000 women like ah yeah i mean
she was a woman's not talking about her
feelings something is off she didn't
give anything
and then there was the two the lead
runner and the second place runner were
like i was in first place at the 18th
mile and then someone was like i was in
second place the 18th mile yeah i didn't
see this [ __ ] woman and so slowly it
took time but after like a week and she
also shaved like
i think like 25 minutes off of her new
york time that's a lyric which is a mile
a minute a woman shave
one i mean one minute a mile
in like i don't know what's october to
april six months so is she a good runner
at all or just she's fine no she's just
a fraud yeah but she had like she had
like a chubby ass and like she had like
like thick legs i like the idea of her
like running up the subway stairs like
trying to [ __ ] herself just you know for
the realism
but yeah she's fascinating and so she do
it you can find all these videos of her
just doing this [ __ ] wow so what's
there what's she doing now is she
working in the government i assume is
she a politician i think she's dead uh
is she looking at yeah i think so
ran its course
but um rosie ruiz ruiz good for her she
died she died in florida
yeah she got what she deserved there you
go
um
damn but anyway sorry we go every year
you go to the it's just a special day
you all get up you have your breakfast
they're all drinking i used to drink a
lot there but i don't know and then you
take you drive i don't enjoy it sober oh
i love it you're driving to the st this
year sarah came for the first time and
you drive in you go to the bar and just
a festive atmosphere the game starts at
11. it's the only pre-noon professional
game in america
and then when the game ends the the
racers have finished and they announce
it on the big screen and everything and
then when you come out it's like the
race has been going on for about three
and a half hours so you get the
slower like blue-collar regular people
coming through and i cry every year i'm
not even like it sounds silly but like
the rooting for people everyone's
rooting and people put their name tag on
oh yeah you're like come on john or they
have like boston police state trooper
fire department i'm running for i'm
running for susan and i'm like do it for
soup yeah and then people give you like
a high five some people run through
doing this and they're videotaping
and then we had our friend you can
follow your friend around oh fun you
have like an app and it tells you where
they're at and it's just it's the subway
what the hell
it just um it gives me uh hope it fills
me with um
uh
joy and love firing yeah it's beautiful
i love it every year you're like i'll
run next year and yeah [ __ ] it but the
best you
one of those things you think or no no i
want to actually if i was i always want
to but then bad for you it just beats
the [ __ ] out of you i mean i used to
when i was a kid like 20 years old i ran
nine miles like quickly and that would
have been the time to do it but then i
started drinking accessibly sure i feel
like you're fast i've seen you run and
you're pretty fast yeah i mean i still
run i still run at a good clip but it's
like run on you
this we were just talking about this
it's like
i have the energy and the lung capacity
to run but now it's like blisters and
shin splints in your knees
but there's guys that are [ __ ] 70
that run yeah crazy and the longer
you're there you watch runners that are
like they're like fat they're like fat
people they're old people they you can
do it it's cool when you see a fat dude
who's fast yeah yeah it's kind of well
[ __ ] a lot of fat guys have amazing
calves because they've got to just
support that crazy disgusting body so
much run-on talk oh yeah
who's also got a special comment that's
right we got it we got to get him on
here too everybody's got a special uh
that's my day it's your day oh he's got
a great podcast called joe and run on
tech movies which i want to just call it
joe and run on talk we have to ditch the
movie now that i'm a movie star
oh yeah
i like that you guys talk movies we talk
this just devolves into movie talk this
podcast so much because we both just
watch a shitload of movies but uh
ronan is a tough dude to talk movies
with he's a [ __ ] hater
yeah he has that reputation too and i
try to be defensive as a guy that gets
that
he has good taste as well i'm not trying
to just slam him he is very good he
hates the first few episodes we're like
we just started talking about classic
movies and he like hates ferris bueller
he thinks john is a bad guy he thinks
john candy sucks what yeah candy
but john hughes bad guy or not the
movies are great
yeah no he's an idiot
that's a bad take it's a bad take well
he's like a conservative john hughes so
he you know ronan thinks he's like in
the kkk or whatever wow all right
but
but movies are good he also uh
he likes movies that are super bleak he
doesn't like anything with like a hint
of he likes sopranos yeah yeah i love
sopranos but he also loves season eight
and nine of seinfeld so he's all over
the place
he thinks they're the best seasons which
i'm like that's literally the worst take
yes thinking seasons eight and nine of
seinfeld are the best seasons is
literally the worst take don't go see it
special i get mad at people for getting
mad at me about the sopranos i'm like
who cares just think what you think but
then when people are like season eight
and nine are the best i'm like you're a
literal piece of [ __ ] yeah it's like i
hope that you die it's like when people
tell your friends is better than
seinfeld you're like oh we can't hang
out you're bored yeah you're a boring
piece of [ __ ] i'm like that with people
that think casino is better than
goodfellas i'm like i can't even have a
dialysis
there's lots of them chris allen is one
chris allen also by the way i just
messaged him today
he said liz hurley elizabeth hurley is
unattractive or not he's that she's not
hot she's still incredibly hot i send
the pictures well today this is our
discussion today i want a picture of
every woman he's put his penis inside if
liz hurley is not hot well here's this
is what this is the dialogue we had
today
he i texted him liz hurley is still
smoking hot i texted him this photo let
me although hugh graham posted her pull
up her instagram that's
trans i believe was she i think she was
trans elizabeth hurley no no the hooker
that hugh grant got
well i want uh if you can get today's
photo she's got a blue baby
there it is it's a classic show me the
best looking girl in the world i'll show
you a guy who's tired of [ __ ] her
that's exactly what is harley and hugh
grant like the what's his face just
cheated on rihanna and then you're like
there you go what's up rocky that's it
so this photo i sent this photo to chris
allen i said i just want to remind you
that your elizabeth hurley's not hot
take is one of the worst takes ever yeah
let's get some more mac trolls uh
current yes dude she's in her 50s and
then so he writes back what do you make
of this he writes back are we doing this
because i could bring up sopranos and my
point are we doing i will make a case
that's the proud i can make it click on
that one jesus christ wow smoking hot
lady i can make a case that sopranos is
not good maybe you disagree but i'll
make an argument now your turn chris
make an argument that this woman is not
attractive yeah well that's the shitty
part is like it's all preference but you
can't say it's like when people go
jennifer anderson's gross you're like oh
you might not like him she's not gross
your wife is gross how about that you
know like you can't just say gross
i always jump straight to wife when
somebody's gotta go like yeah i don't
you don't like the sopranos your wife is
gross and i [ __ ] your mom how do you
like that remember bobby kelly's old
joke about the guy that doesn't know how
to bust balls
yeah [ __ ] you you suck yeah i heard your
mom's sick
not dying doesn't have not cancer she's
sick well sick is an umbrella
um
oh boy that's cool that's basically what
these roasts have come down to it's just
like your mom has cancer your dad was
shot in the face you know your daughter
was a miscarriage whatever yeah that's
these roasts now yeah it's crazy i heard
you got assaulted let me work at a tight
five on that just be like you drink a
lot you know
you're fat now it's just going straight
to uh
horrific [ __ ] by the way the roast every
the most the thing i'm most talking
about with interviews that people that
aren't my friends is the roast battle
with sarah that's like the number one
it's amazing that you did it with your
wife i mean that's pretty it's pretty
hilarious it's i guess so it's so weird
to me because we're just comics and i'm
in the relationship so to me it's just
like yeah we just did a thing yeah well
you're just outside like this is insane
you're both
good joke writer so it's like
to get it it's a hilarious thing like
think about how many people can actually
do that yeah well we didn't even write
the jokes tom dustin did but
funny guy d.d just uh blew out his
achilles oh what that's bad how he was
like pushing a boat in waters achilles
erupted we got to like well he's like i
think there's like a gofundme he needs
surgery oh he's got no money send money
to tom dust he's uh he's in key west
probably dustin yeah
give give the real name if you're not
dustin sorry
don't do nicknames
some guy named tom dust just got like
three
grand um yeah there was up that well
achilles is tom dust right now yeah the
uh it was not a gofundme but whatever
the [ __ ] it's called but it was up for
like a day yeah and then that's horrible
wow yeah i don't know i'll i'll send you
a little that's a long recovery for an
athlete so yeah for regular people that
ain't good no somebody said they're like
well they put a cast on it and they're
hoping he doesn't need surgery i'm like
yeah maybe that pack of cigarettes a day
for 30 years will help that achilles
heel yeah right well we'll see so yeah
we're gonna
we'll send them some hilarious guy you
ever do that rome you should do that i
should do it where is it key west
bad it's fun not for you yeah it's fun
it's great i went it was awesome
but mark we should do it today i'll show
open black socks sneakers and uh in a
hot coffee yeah yeah with the post
yeah yeah that key west is a it's a
magical place you go down there your
problems melt right off yeah we did jet
skis all day we drank all day the shows
are fun yeah it's fun it's probably a
chiropractor i'm sure
yeah there you go get your neck
maybe they got a tv with the knicks game
something
do you have do you have any bits you
want to try uh i dude i've been like
i've been on a vacation i'm i'm afraid
to like i'm like i blocked your number
in my phone because i've been gone for
10 days i haven't even kind of written
anything you got to have an idea brewing
just something i mean even the thing you
said about the baseball game is funny
what do you mean yeah
this is where we're different this is
where we're different and we're very
different
i go on vacation the whole thing is off
i'm out i'm just out on comedy and then
i'll i'll pump it out when i'm
you know i like i care about family and
friends and stuff yeah
weird you guys are more successful it's
a sliding scale you know there you go
yeah a lot of these just are bits
uh you guys you got one i got one i'm
trying let me tell you what you think
about this come on let me go through
notes okay everybody's looking at their
notes uh
airfield time here okay this is an idea
i had everything's backwards now like it
used to be like what do you do on a date
now you ask what their mental illness is
oh yeah do you know what i mean like
like you know she's got borderline
personality while while you're having
appetizers and then like three months in
you're like oh software engineer
that's funny you learn that later yeah
yeah yeah that's funny i like that
someone there all right i'll play with
it yeah that's funny all right all right
that's funny that's how you do you
really save it i'm like this is [ __ ]
i know all right mine is a
completely half-baked idea oh here's a
tweet i wrote down this video
but um you know how like
nolan ryan has seven no hitters but he
has like 21 one hitters which is like
more impressive
like he's got seven no-hitters which is
amazing but like 21-hitter like he
almost had 30 no hitters right i'm
exactly like that with [ __ ] my pants
i've [ __ ] my pants like seven times but
i've almost [ __ ] my pants
i like it
anyways at
the very least it's a great start
yes let me double check that because on
podcasts
you say a thing people like you [ __ ]
retired he had 30 one hit i'm like i
know sorry so let me just get i can't
focus on the numbers i got the right
thing here yeah that one right i think
it's 21 though 12 excuse me i reversed
it i'm dyslexic i got mine it sucks too
but is there anything here about how
like
to me uh
lgbtq is weird because trans most of
them
lesbian gay bi is all about your sexual
preference who you're attracted to but
trans is just a gender issue so it has
really nothing to do with who you're
attracted to so it almost feels like my
racist uncle made that list like ah
they're all weird put them together you
know it's almost like when you're uh
your grandfather's like
he thinks everybody from asia is chinese
you know how he puts them all together
i don't know
it feels weird that those are lumped
together because they trans has nothing
to do with gay i think it's an excellent
point well i need the bit keen
observation though okay but i think the
china thing could happen the china thing
is a funny is a funny uh connection like
we should get we should get sushi i hate
chinese food you know your grandfather
just thinks everybody asian is chinese
[Applause]
no it's amazing it's on showtime yeah
it's really good that's probably why i
haven't seen it yeah showtime but they
do it they do make good docs on showtime
yeah
it's showtime at the apollo it's a
documentary about murder yes
they sweep you off and kill you they
hook your neck yeah
what about this is this anything let me
let me redeem myself
i was watching the news and it was like
the local news and this guy was a pizza
delivery driver he saw a guy get held up
at gunpoint and he called the police and
the reporter was like why didn't you
step in and he goes [ __ ] i make ten
dollars an hour you think i'm stepping
in blah blah and i'm like well what is
the money matter if you were a
millionaire would you be like oh my god
why did you run in that burning building
like well i make a million dollars a
year i feel like i had to do something
right yeah you know yeah so you're like
i feel like if i'm if i'm rich i'm more
likely to like not want to go yeah
yeah and as if domino's paid you 40
grand a year or 40 grand an hour or 40
dollars an hour you'd be like all right
i should step in right they pay me well
well it's like he heard that from
someone else saying when it makes sense
because it makes sense like
if uh
somebody robs a restaurant and then runs
and they say to the busboy go get him
right and he's like i make seven dollars
an hour i'm not going for that yeah that
makes sense in the context he's like out
that's outside of my
job description right
but this case like it sounds like that
guy's just stealing someone else's point
that made sense i see it's also like
you're like at uh
but even with the busboy you're like
well you should you could just help too
but the burning boney has nothing to do
with dominos
and the guy that held up in guppy yeah
yeah yeah i'm saying yeah yeah that's
why it's funny oh i see
i see
there's something here for sure yeah
like if domino's paid more you would you
would
fight crime also you know
all right
there's something there all right yeah
and also police make very little money
too so you could throw that in yeah yeah
you think i'm gonna cop do you think i'm
going in there i make fourteen dollars
an hour yeah exactly
this is just a a joke for a movie or a
sketch
maybe it's been done there's a guy
talking to his girlfriend as a guy
talking to his buddy about his breakup
and he's like don't worry she'll find
someone better
he says that to the friend
you just broke up and i say don't worry
yeah find someone better oh yeah that's
fun yeah nice turn but not a
stand-up i mean i'm not kidding i
haven't written anything in three weeks
all right yeah what else you got i feel
like we did too
um
oh
hit me
what about this this is actually a
premise that i've said nine times on
stage but i have no joke you remember
those things in the the waiting room
with the uh you have like a block that
goes around the wall the wire remember
that thing and like the doctors oh yeah
the kids yes oh yeah the little things
that's like practice for taking a
woman's underwear off like you gotta
pull it around the butt and then up down
the knee and then off the foot it's kind
of similar interesting that's all i have
that kind of stuff because it's a
similar thing you're pulling the panties
right around the loop and there's a
loop-de-loop there you go yeah
something
i used to have a thing now i saw michael
rowland has a similar bit so i dropped
mine but it was about how you're trying
to very good he's got good stuff trying
to turn a tv a flat screen tv on is like
feeling up a woman you're like oh i
think i felt the nub there that could be
something that's funny but he i think he
does it and mine was working a little
bit and his kill so i just dropped mine
he's really good yeah he's got i quoted
one of his bits a couple weeks ago on
this he's he's got good stuff yeah this
might be nothing let me try this it's uh
i was thinking about pre-cum babies like
that
well that's like well that's crazy that
can happen i wrote a it's like it's like
i wonder if you can tell who's a pre-cum
baby like maybe they show up early to
parties they weren't invited to oh is
that something like that yeah i like
that
they get there too early yeah and you're
like oh we weren't expecting you yeah
we didn't think you would
show up you weren't really wanted here
well maybe there's a twist yeah and
they're also they suck to be around
because their parents are shitty or
whatever right the twist is also
you can tell that way but you can also
tell because uh they've never
experienced love
and they
they ruin the party like a kid would
ruin a party you ruined yeah this isn't
the first party you ruined yeah
something like that yeah all right
there's i'll play with that there's
something there
that's funny i like that
it's like a stephen wright's joke about
a i was born cesarean section you know
so now every time i leave a house i go
out the window oh that's good oh it
seems [ __ ] classic oh yeah i love his
bit about uh i forgot to take my
seatbelt off on the plane so
embarrassing i'm like i'm dragging the
plane through the lobby yeah yeah
i love his joke i went to a diner city
uh eat breakfast any time so i ordered
french toast during the renaissance yes
that's a great joke he's great classic
classic jokes couldn't find my socks so
i called information they said they're
behind the couch
damn so deadpan i know i actually
uh came home late i put my car key in
the my apartment door and the whole
building started up
oh my god reminds me of kylie brian
kylie
jokes some of the best
i can't even say without laughing
because i got my for her birthday i got
my eight-year-old daughter a bouncy
castle i paid for it with a bouncy check
oh
damn bouncy
bouncy chicken bouncy check
he's a little baby what is he yeah he's
like my wife gets uh drunk gets really
ah i call my wife pumpkin because you
get smashed around the holidays uh he's
got the other one uh well he's got a
bunch but i'm six foot five my wife is
five eight so she has no idea that i'm
bald
i love that one also he had the one
about his brother at a heart attack and
the doctor said he could have sex again
when you can walk up a flight of stairs
and he goes why who's up there oh
i like the classic jokes
oh wait i'm so irish my blood type is oh
apostrophe there's a great line
that one's great and then the uh married
girl twice's age you know that one with
the baby he had his he had his back i
mean i gave him a punchline first but he
he has a baby and he's at the the
maternity ward and there's a guy next to
him and he's like um
yeah this is my my son he was born today
and the guy next to him goes that was my
daughter she was born yesterday and then
he's like who knows maybe they're
getting married and he's like my son's
not going to marry a woman twice his age
oh
wow that's great
amazing i thought there's twitter right
now that's what i'm doing he tweets
stuff he gets like seven favorites
because he's got no followers i gotta
follow him
i follow him uh he was a conan writer
for many years great great jokes i mean
i discovered in my dr cats i think i'm
starting to think my dad has a gambling
problem last week he lost me in a poker
game
i bombed hard in front of him once in an
la bar show and it crushed me because i
was such a fan
it was a brutal bomb he's ripped too
he's a he told me he would just watch
this yeah i think he would just watch
the red sox games on like two speed so
it would speed it up while he was just
like running on a treadmill and i was
like this dude's just like a machine
yeah he jokes and yeah
he's great now i'm just reading tweets
sorry
will we plug your plug the special the
movie where you're gonna be is this two
episodes i feel like i've been here for
a month oh i don't know where it's you
so we've went a little long oh jesus
christ i'm falling over um
where am i gonna be uh those are all i
gotta update my website obviously
um i'm not good at business what do you
got in like the summertime what's
cooking out there in the future oh i got
atlanta june 24th 25th same weekend the
movie's uh premiere it's gonna premiere
we think uh at the um beacon theater i
believe wow another beacon yes the
beacon theater
um maybe i shouldn't say that it's not
fully booked yet but um
anyways uh the the movie's coming out
soon i'm gonna be um in atlanta
punchline june 24th and 25th and then uh
august uh oh june 9th through the
11th i think our 8th through the 10th
i'm at san francisco punchline oh i love
that in um august i'm in nashville for
the first time i've never worked now
yeah that's a blast and then the
special's out right now it's called this
year's material joe list on youtube
movies coming out in a month but the
special is the main thing go watch that
it's amazing
you're one of the best you're one of the
best not just working but period you're
really you're really one of my favorite
comics you got a great podcast oh thank
you i got i got
1100 podcasts uh mindful metal jackets
coming back this next month
and then joe and ron on talk movies on
youtube which i'm gonna
quit because i'm a bad person and of
course tuesdays with stories every
tuesday you're here and i can say i was
at the the the we were both there at the
taping it was amazing lights out so
that's gonna be a hot one
and uh yeah what do you got what are you
gonna be uh end of the month toronto
we're doing two uh two theater shows
there bloom it's gonna be great uh
providence chicago taping a special
tampa cleveland houston west palm uh
buffalo san jose you get the deal
samerworld.com shows there you go i'm at
mark normancomedy.com all kinds of good
stuff stand up live irvine improv doing
some dates with chris shirt a pantages
theater in minneapolis uh cleveland at
the agora
all kinds of fun stuff give it a whirl
tuesdays with stories uh we might be
drunk get on the patreon get a glass get
a shirt go nuts kill yourself [ __ ] your
dad praise allah thank you sunday's the
day for my next bender
[Music]
and naked samuel is feeling dangerous
i'm out to lunch here in new orleans
this woman doesn't look like i remember
her and i get down in the same way
we
might be
true
[Music]